supreme and we were in the elevator in
an elevator should we take the elevator
up before I'll push along small Alabama
we explore this more neighbors are some
really good to shoot yeah let's see hey
guys how's it goes we're trying to find
some nice to shoot a video in this hotel
and thats quiet and this has got quiet
and lights quiet it might look like
there's a lot of like this cuz i have a
light on my camera if I turn this alone
what color it is oh what's this oh so
how's this look upstairs rooms I'm all
right here this looks nice look at you
right here let's just sit Shanon boo boo
boo stop shouting baby I'm ready to go
oh we're on the roof wait
did I open that or did you have a listen
hurry let's do it already and we're on
the roof Jenna I don't know I hope you
don't fall whoa-oa this is probably
somebody's house what about you she's
okay i set my camera right here what's
over there oh and you shot it y'all miss
the King stunned that's see that Dean of
dumb dumb don't welcome to miami on the
emo ama um I me me that what they say
see if you can open it wait i can have
to get a panoramic shot so well just a
sunset pic really i just wanted to tell
you about our miami trip orlando trip
sorry about that noise over there it's
uh the roof zombies house would be well
there's nobody here let's just shoot
right here I mean whatever it doesn't
even matter so we're basically on top of
Group right now yeah we are we would see
Orlando playlist this past weekend we
got to meet so many of you guys
not a lot of people I'm sick I'm so
sorry if I get any of you guys sick we
had stickers and postcards and sharpies
to give out to you guys but there's my
little sticker she got me she's her
stickers ready sharpies just tweeting
and getting the tweets ready getting the
tweets ready let's go and then after
playlist we decided to go to Miami and I
thought the drive would be what are you
okay three half hours supposed to be how
many hours it takes f7 I mean we haven't
even taken off yet just seeing your pig
there's a pig on a classic Florida five
capacities Carrie what we don't know
what the speed limit is soy please tell
dudes be look no sign he and Perry well
let's see those are directions we made
our first stop and the power is out in
the pilot station like I have to pee
whoa what is happening around this is
amazing risking Pokemon know and you
drove what seemed to be like three hours
was actually half an hour just keep
getting off exits and we're not even
sure if we're right thank you look at
you drivin there's your so attentive
right now then I drove her ass tomorrow
none 409 we both still have two hours to
drive and then there was an accident
then we couldn't buy a Dunkin Donuts cuz
we were starving and then I know and I
got a coffee at dunkin donuts decided to
go back through because i didn't like my
coffee and then you didn't know what or
anything and i was like sorry I'm just
kidding I thought the Duncan dark roast
was gonna be good and I don't like it go
back around I think okay I asked him at
a dunkaccino is okay wait I don't didn t
know it helped I didn't know you guys
give your ax sorry that sounds good we
finally get to Miami we're really
excited because uh you're staying at the
Perry hotel which was supposed to like a
really nice hotel mmm yeah construction
site oh good morning oh it's eight
o'clock the what I do here that sounds
like this buildings falling down oh it
oh yeah no we haven't looked at the
window and there is a man just then we
finally switch hotels guys you cramp
back there yeah we're at the one that
we're currently at on top of the roof
where the Sun is setting and it's so
dark inside that we can't shoot any
videos so dark in here I can see a
freaking thing and literally have like
my flashlight app I was like oh look at
that look at how I should use that look
at that wow you really want that up I
just feel like everything but having
this trip went wrong Ryan got really
sick he had to fly home two days or at
least three degree i was using my
flashlight up well I think you guys for
watching and I had so much fun meeting
all of you guys at playlist and I want
to know about your vacation disasters
this wasn't really a disaster but I know
some people have had some super crazy
disaster so leave us in comments let us
know and we'll see you in the next video
good thing you brought this late i move
about and i think there's somebody in
here too
we're heading out of this person's yard
and something I forgot to add I'm so
excited because we're right now well we
haven't gone there yet we're going to my
favorite place it's called Barton G it's
amazing restaurant where they give you
like these really big props with your
food we in Miami